حجم الكارثه الكبير اللي بتعيشوا سوريا
وتركيا والتطورات المستجده اليوميه اللي
بنشهدها بتخلي الزلزال عنوان وموضوع رئيسي
ووحيد في حلقاتنا من ايام ضحايا الزلزال
بيزيدوا يوم بعد يوم والحصيله اليوم قاربت
العشرين الف قتيل في سوريا وتركيا
والاعداد مرشحه للارتفاع هذا غير عشرات
الالاف من الجرحى والالاف من المفقودين
اللي لازالوا تحت الانقاض وكمان خلال
الساعات الماضيه استمرت الهزات الارتداديه
والزلازل وسمعنا عن تسجيل زلزال في منطقه
جنوب تركيا خمسه فاصله واحد وكمان زلزال
ثاني تم تسجيله على الحدود السوريه
اللبنانيه شده كانت اربعه فاصله ثلاثه
ويبدو انه اثار الزلزال والهزات
الارتداديه تجاوزت شمال سوريا ووصلت الى
اطراف العاصمه دمشق وخصوصا في مدينه
او الانهار فيها ليلا مبنى مؤلف من اربع
طوابق وتسكن في عائلتين
وعلى الرغم من هول الماسه ومرور اربع ايام
على الزلزال لكن في ناس لسه رجال بتطلع من
تحت الانقاض حيه ناس انكتب لها عمر جديد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر
يعني اللي بنشوفه خلال عمليات الانقاذ
وعلى الرغم من الالم اللي فيه لكن في جانب
مفرح وهو الاطفال والشباب والمسنين
بيطلعوهم من تحت الانقاض بعد ايام من
الزلزال وايام معلقين فيها بلا اكل ولا
شرب وكمان نقص فيه الاكسجين ومع ذلك
متمسكين في الحياه وما زالوا احياء
الخبراء الان جالسين بيقولوا انه مع مرور
الوقت فرص العثور على ناجين طبعا بتقل لكن
رغم ذلك ممكن للسيده يلاقوناجين وهذا
الشيء بياخدنا السؤال مهم كيف في ناس رغم
اصابتها ورغم ايام من غير اكل وشرب بتصمت
تحت الانقاض هل في ظروف معينه مثلا بتضمن
صموتهم عبر سكايب من شمال سوريا مدير
الدفاع المدني السوري الخوض البيضاء
الرائد صالح اهلا فيك معنا ويعطيكم
العافيه على جهودكم اذا في البدايه ممكن
توضح لنا بشكل عام قدي ايش مده استمرار
عمليات البحث
عن الناجين يعني
تحياتي لك ولساده المشاهدين حقيقه موضوع
البحث عن الناجين يعني مستمر الى الان منذ
بدايه الزلزال
وصل عدد الناجين الزلزال الذين تم
استخراجهم
وعدد الاشخاص الذين استخرجناهم فقدوا
حياتهم
1950 الان
مثل ما قالوا الخبراء يعني اكيد هذا
الموضوع هو المعروف للكل انه نحن فعليا
هلا يعني صار شبه الامل معدوم انه نلاقي
ناجين تحت الانقاب بسبب انه صار فتره
طويله على الزلزال
يعني تنتقل للفرق لعمليات انتشال الجسد هو
كل يوم كان هناك انتشار جثث للضحايا
وستستمر يعني العمليه ممكن عده ايام اخرى
لحتى ننتهي من الاعمال بشكل كامل انتهينا
من بعض مواقع
ادلب المدينه مدينه ادلب وجسر الشغور
والملاند والرمادي كونها كانت يعني اقل
ضررا من ودانا وسرمدا لونها قاعد اقل ضرب
باقي المناطق كجنديرس وحارم وسلقين وبسنه
وعزمارين وهذه المناطق حقيقه يعني
العمل مستمر الى الان موجوده نحن في كافه
المناطق غطيناها بنسبه مئه بالمئه لم يعد
هناك منطقه واحده متضرره من
الثجيب لها كفرق دفاع مدني بس هل في لا
زالت مثلا يعني خلينا نقول قرى صغيره او
اماكن لسه ما وصل طولها
تم الوصول حقيقه اول ما بدانا عمليات
البحث والانقاذ
ركزنا على الاماكن الكبيره وبعدها يعني
استنفرنا كافه فرقنا الموجوده بشمال سوريا
واستجبنا لكافه القرى الصغيره
دقيقتين وتم انهاء الاعمال ولكن حقيقه
الرابعه صباحا تفاجانا في امر انه في احد
ان النظام السوري افتتح سد الرستن بشكل
كامل وهذا ما سبب ارتفاع لمنسوب المياه في
نهر العاصي وادى الى اغراق مخيم وقريه
بلول على الحدود السوريه التركيه
استجبنا لها في الساعه الرابعه صباحا من
هذا اليوم
واخلينا المدنيين من المناطق ولم يتضرر
احد ولم يكن هناك
العمل الفيديوهات اللي بتوثق عمليات
الانقاذ يعني ماليه المواقع والشاشات شيء
وصراحه لحظات يعني مؤثره وسعيده بس السؤال
كمان اللي يسالوه الناس انه كيف بيتم او
انه كيف هدول الناس تمكنوا من البقاء
احياء خلال الاربعاء ايام وهم تحت الانقاض
يعني
فعليا لا يستطيع احد البقاء حي تحت
الانقاض الا اذا يعني حقيقه هي قدره الهيه
يعني لمده اربع بعد اربع ايام تكون الامل
معدوم لكن بالثلاثه ايام الاولى هناك
الانسان يستطيع ان يصمد فتره بين الزمن
يعني اذا كان لديه اكسجين بشكل كافي ونحن
فعليا عندما نسمع اي صوت في اي مكان اول
شيء ممكن يعمله فريق الدفاع المدني هو
تزويد هذا الشخص بالاكسجين يتم تجين
وتزويد وكان اذا حقيقه احتاج ايضا الى اذا
راينا بانه جسمه ضعيف فنعطي له سيروم حتى
يستطيع ان يستعيد صحته قبل ان يتم عمليه
الانتشار لانه ممكن بعد ان نجده يكون هناك
عم قتل باطونيه او امور اخرى تعيق وحقيقه
كون الفتره الزمنيه التي حدث بها الزلزال
كانت الناس كلها نائمه
فكثير حقيقه من الاشخاص الذين استطعنا
انقاذهم بسبب حمايتهم من قبل الاشخاص معهم
يعني
معظم الاطفال الذين انقذناهم وهذا يعني
حقيقه مناظر مؤثره ومبكيه هم كانوا في حضن
ابائهم او في حضن امهاتهم كانوا يحمونهم
من الزلزال فكانوا هم الضحيه ونجا الطفل
من هذه العمليات هناك بعض الاطفال الذين
نجوا فقدوا كل عائلاتهم لم يبقى احد من
عائلاتهم لذلك يعني عمليه الانقاذ هي
دائما تاخذ وقت طويل يعني انت بعض
طفلي في مدينه حارم اول البارحه انقذنا في
في الساعه تقريبا
حتى تم استخراجها من ناحيه الانقاض ولكن
عمليه الاستخراج استغرقت 16 ساعه كامله
تقريبا من العمل لا نستطيع يعني نحن عندما
نكون هناك بعض الصعوبات والعوائق الكبيره
التي واجهتنا بها
حيث انه لا يوجد مخططات سكنيه لهذه
المباني فنحن لا نعرف لا نعلم ان المطبخ
لا نعلم اين غرف النوم لا نعلم اين
الصالون فكان عنده من اجد شخص
على قيد الحياه تحت المبنى ونستخرجه كاننا
حقيقه هو كنز هو كنز ليس فقط
هو كنز من المعلومات هو يعطينا المعلومات
الكامله اين يتواجد الاهالي ان يتواجد اين
ينامون في اي مكان يستريحون في هذا الوقت
هذا يعطينا حقيقه سرعه في الاستجابه سرعه
في الوصول في الضحايا
يعني صراحه يعطيكم العافيه او كل فيديو
بيطلع وخصوصا الفيديوهات اللي بتنشروها
على حساباتكم يعني بتحيي فينا الامل ويعني
فعلا بنشعر بالتاثر وخصوصا النقطه اللي
قلتها انه كثير من الاهالي حموا باجسادهم
ابنائهم وعشان كذا الابناء الصغار تمكنوا
من
النجاح في سؤال بس بعض الناس كانوا
بيسالوه على مواقع التواصل انه ما بتعطوا
لما بيكون الشخص لا زال تحت الانقاض ما
بتعطوا له ماء او اكل او اي شيء من هذا
القبيل بتستنوا تطلعوا اول
ما ما ابدا ما بنقدر نعطي ماء لانه نحن ما
بنعرف حالته صحيه يعني ممكن تشرح لنا هذه
النقطه
يعني نحن لا نستطيع الماء هو خطير جدا في
هذه الحاله يمكن ان لا نعلم هو عدم قدرته
ممكن نعطيه بعض الماء حتى نمسح به فمه
ولكن لا نكتبهما تحت الانقاذ حتى الاكل
يعني ممكن نعطي قسم من بسكوتي ولا يمكن ان
اعطائك يعني شيء اله علاقه سكريات خفيفه
حتى لا الجسم لا يعني اذا كانت فارغه حتى
نحن الناس الذين لسنا تحت الانقاذ اذا
بقينا يومين بدون طعام وجئنا اكلنا بشكل
مفاجئ فتحدث لدينا اضطرابات جسديه فكيف
الشخص المصاب لذلك لا يمكن يعني اذا كان
الشخص بحاجه الى تغذيه او بحاجه الى
طاقه فنعطيه يتم ربط سيروم يتم فتح وريد
واعطاء سيروم ملحي او سكر حتى يستطيع
الفكره
نعم نحن بنشكرك ويعطيكم العافيه وعلى كل
جهودكم وان شاء الله المزيد من الاخبار
المفرحه كان معنا عبر سكايب من شمال سوريا
مدير الدفاع المدني السوري الخوض البيضاء
رائد الصالح شكرا لك
[موسيقى]